ユーチューバーをやってきて今まで様々な機微シリーズをやってきましたが今回は
さらなる高みを目指すためにさらに難しい1シリーズに挑戦してみようと思います今日
乗船する受診率はこちら
チキンショッピングモールの下でございます
エビもお願いしますどう出かけがこの挑戦
そうですねぇまだいろいろで買い出し行くじゃないですか
そそうそれです間していいかよくショッピングが俺結構行ってるんですよね僕特に好き
なショッピングモールが座主粉もう
こちらから名前ないようになってしまったんですけどもう子供の頃からジャスコの店内
bgm が好きで金ノートみたいな
風スコアほぼ壁的だったら100
[音楽]
ブーブー言いセンターなつパートナー皆さんち池戸そうですねっ
2を言うと actor 入ってコーナーにが誰でも親しみやすい種右花木書なんか
ショッピングモールないんですよ
きっと何けど子供の声が入ってくれてくるよねこらぼこなくなったという
ディズニーランドの線の端も増えず食べ特徴があるんで多分店内の音を聴けば絶対
わかると思うけどさすがに明日がには絶対絶対100%する
アブ嘘やでも何事やってみないとわからないぞ5店舗つのどこかの
ブーブー
香川もまあでと歳じゃなしでそれだ自分
わかりますかはい前代未聞だと思うんですよねうんゴンあるじゃないですかにも見せ
たろにしましょう
日本正解ですよと思いますよにも見捨てるにもミッターでいいよ
ロンドンにぶつかった
2回ミスったら警報があるわけはいというわけでえっとケージに一門から5文字見て
もらったんでちょっと全部聞いてから当てたんですが色々と比較しながら考えと思い
ますでは1番目
はい
だーっマーケティリスナー一番ん
2番キーですか維持ますはいはい
ああああああ
[音楽]
やかましいな2番じゃう構っていいねなんかたぶん
若い若い世代のような気もしないけどちょっと1回一通り聴いています様お願いします
入っていきます
ああああああ
あああっあっーはいもう流 s かアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアア
3番はティファールっしゃあああああっ
イトーヨーカドーが dj ブーバーこれはけどねーよんっ
[音楽]
いやー
構成見にきてくだ2本当にのサイズみたいなに聞こえたんだよなんて爽やかないねっ何
か良い音なんですよね
小鳥のさえずりがすごいなきゃいんぱくは必要な価値をしますてちょっと
5番目も聴いてみませんであったよはいお願いします
はぁ
[拍手]
お前はなぜ聞き取れんかったまずアプたって言ったらいいですよ
重いキーですかん
秋田です釣会でふーん当てたフィットリフレてるんですねセールストーク
あの店員さんの sas とグーすぐしっかりしましたね素晴らしいでございます
m のところ3番が012と4ですねって登っている選択肢がいせターン制のバー
4いけるこれたぶんこれでいけるよねー
ちょっと一番お願いします1バイバイ
いっ
いやーこのピンポンパンモンキーでをなるんだろうなぁ
いやめっちゃ落ち着いてに水あるんだよなぁ
今お願いします
[拍手]
な英語でつい声で皆さんだけどなんかインターナショナルチェックなイメージあるのが
伊勢丹なんですよね
ジョンをキレティ
小鳥のさえずりなんでます
鳥のさえずりがポイントな気がするなぁはからこれはウエパチェックすると良い音は猫
とにのサイズになった子サイクルのイメージがあるんでことに疲れたりがたのは4番
ですよねとなりました40,000
イオンでスパイなランスあ
tale
同じ
机相まってん
いうのはいえば小鳥のさえずりがポイントだったらいいよなんかそういうイメージが
あるんだよな的だって政界から徒歩7分いやもうか膣にも失いですあっそっか
婚活それじゃつまんねーなー次外したらもーちゃ今年ショップもいいかなよ
次外さの俺をいかによっ ok もういかね助けて
俺はこの企画世界右腕を失って俺あと残っているのが選抜にセダンどっちかですね
まあいやっ send ばこそなんかこう目指せ大バコそんなピンポンパンポンの射水
カルネ1番線の場です
by $ author ファイナルアンサー
一番ハイん
せーの版ん
分
ん
一番はいっ
うん
のバーン
ん
じゃありません
市西端で泥で切ります
聞いたリコールは完璧ですけど小さなただこれは買って来なくなった
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
うううう
car
あっはぁ
ああああっってことなんですよねパンダなんかシンプルにエフェターンが高級な
イメージがあるからわかるアナウンサー上の高級そんな声とピンポンパンポンの判事で
伊勢丹にしたけど解けたかもしれないですね最初めっちゃあるんですよ
最初一番油断で著名なんですよ
でそのままぽっくるが来るかと思ってたらいけるかさが飛んで
ゼロはプレイ中ですねちょっと英語にサインされちゃいますね今回もある
なるほどんじゃねーからいやー読みは良かったですよでもすごい